make it right I'm going to talk about
why that's important in today's episode
of lunch and earn so that's what that
was in LA on a business trip and one of
the things that I had to do was a
hangout with Aweber and a weber is the
email marketing software that I use in
every month we do a different hang out
and it was super excited for this one
because I was going to be talking with
one of their project managers about how
to manage your time it's a topic that I
love and I was really curious to find
out their perspective on it and the deal
that I made was we're going to do a half
an hour hang out and put that online and
share with you guys and gives you
knowledge it also helps promote a weber
and i was doing it from the air B&B
place that i was at in 25 minutes into
the session the internet cuts out
there's this big power failure across LA
and my powerful my my internet shuts off
I can't connect and suddenly my co-host
is left not knowing what to do and
ending up closing down the chat maybe
answering one or more one or two more
questions and I felt bad I felt bad that
you know I didn't end it on a high feel
bad for you guys watching there wasn't a
great experience it felt bad for him for
having to be on and not knowing what to
do next and even though i gave them
close to what they wanted right I give
them 25 minutes out of the 30 I felt bad
that it wasn't right you know like I had
to make it right and I think this is an
opportunity for a lot of entrepreneurs
because you're going to make mistakes in
your business you're going to have
people who you let down your service
won't be fantastic your product will
fail on you you will have technical
difficulties you know you will not live
up to everybody's expectations every
single time it's noble goal and
definitely worth striving for but you're
going to make mistakes it's an
opportunity though for you to then
cement your relationship and make them
love you because you go above and beyond
to rectify the situation so what I did
was I flew home the next day and I said
guys let's do this again let's do let's
do the session again we'll start over
from where we work pick it up and
provide more value and I invited you
guys back on and invited the Aweber guys
back on and we did another full session
that I didn't charge them for and
because I was so worried about the
internet I went to an internet cafe back
here in Toronto and city to make sure
that we had
all the internet for the entire half
hour and ended up going over but just
making sure that they had a really good
experience and so I did that for free
right even though I had to I had to fly
back home I had to do a crazy amount of
marketing and promotion to set it up to
you know do that extra work for free to
come on and do another hang out with you
guys because it was the right thing to
do because it was the right thing for
you guys as the audience to do because
the right thing for my client with a
Weber and because because it was at the
end of the day the right thing to do and
I think a lot of entrepreneurs you may
as you make these mistakes apologize and
you may lose your clients because of the
mistakes you make where if you not only
apologize but make it right find a way
to make them happy whatever that takes
it means you not getting paid it means
you spending extra hours it means you
put it in you know the time of your team
and effort and resources to make sure
that they are happy because that then if
you can turn that situation around
you'll often get that customers a
customer for life because everybody
understands that mistakes will be made
it's how you handle it and if you can
make sure that they are happy then
they're going to tell their friends
about you they're going to want to keep
coming back and it's a huge opportunity
for your business so make it right so
the question for you guys today is I
want to hear a story from you about how
you've made it right for your customers
or flip side an example of a customer
that made it right company that made it
right for you you had a bad experience
and they turned it around shared in the
comments below because I think it could
really help give some practical examples
to people who are struggling with this
issue so thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon